when you're looking at this device we
know that they're going to say it's it's
faster it's thinner it's bigger it's
better it's the best iPad ever why is
this announcement important as we get
into the holiday sales uh they're going
to need to help improve Revenue there
it's the second largest revenue producer
for apple and it's been decreasing last
two quarters so they need a little more
magic in that lineup for them it's
fairly amazing in that respect that it
became the second bestselling product
that they make of all the things that
they make who could who could imagine
anything would rival what the phone
business has become for them but the
iPad quickly leap frogged PCS and of
course the iPod to become this really
world changing device in the world of
business and the question would be it be
really interesting to see how it plays
out with the larger iPhone now you got
the 6 Plus and then you have the other
hand you're going to have the the the
iPad Mini so this is going to be some
interesting kind of cross pollination
there and and 12 in do we expect the big
one we're expecting that probably next
year so not not till next year yeah
interesting you know Apple to keep such
a a secretive tough hold on on on on all
their their sort of secrets that that
you know you wonder how that might
affect sales knowing there's something
else coming yeah we're expecting the uh
the current big one and the uh the mini
that's already out there as you see
we're updates to those we're also
expecting some updates to the
Mac Tim I want to know about colors am I
going to be able to get a gold iPad to
go with my gold iPhone 6 that's what
sources are telling us that uh add a
little Pizzaz to the
lineup I mean that's how iaz yeah maybe
if my gr I mean I hav't heard the word
Pizzaz I think since Liberace um do you
think maybe Apple needed a bit more time
since they clearly had some issues
around the iPhone does it seem like
maybe they could give themselves a bit
more time as far as testing goes before
another grand reveal I mean they don't
want to have another
hiccup well traditionally Apple releases
the or introduces the new iPad in
October that's what they did last year
um the the hook the the hiccups they had
with the iPhone 6 uh had to do with the
larger screens so we're not expecting a
a larger iPad screen at this point so
production-wise it should be U rather uh
uh routine for them at this point